they don't have a half-asian face
setting they only got full Asian I'm
sorry to tragedy this one might be
closed oh my god the facial hair in this
game is so sick you've got to get
yourself some of this 1930s era
holy [ __ ] that's amazing but they don't
have just stubble I can't do the full
beard myself they don't have a
middle-aged balding hairdo I guess let's
go full bald they don't see you wait
they're not they're not out here for you
they don't see you I'm sorry I have
never played this game is there anything
I should know I have zero hours in game
either so you know we're fine let's be
fine wait hi then I got you to a tee
they didn't have wait yeah wait that's
straight up way to the weightiest thing
I've ever seen thank you oh [ __ ] that
actually hurt you okay no it just pushes
you okay okay I mean we're gonna want to
go in here yeah yeah apparently who'd
have thought that with your mouth I
would have told you what you you asked
that with your mouth
oh I'm sleeping why are there two bags
in three of us clearly lay down look
through my head you have eyes in the
back of your eyes always eyes in the
back your head that one I got stuff out
here guys okay out there oh this is our
crash ship okay I guess I guess there's
nothing of value in this ship full of
technology that's only mostly destroyed
have a wood man calendar back here Oh
what whoa we both go right back
that's like one but he's looking I mean
it looks like me kinda I think it's me
okay there's a waiting calendar oh my
god you pushed me out of the way come on
it's my turn
what kind of calendar is this with
10-day weeks should we um yeah play the
game oh sure so it's the survival game
so I'm assuming punch a tree right well
I mean we spawned with hammer which is
convenient so maybe hammer a tree I
guess and I'm hammering it oh it is oh
my god you were right what's the
survival game that's whoa the tree
really just explodes into okay what stop
rolling away from me I'm refining a log
oh yeah wait how do we it's this refine
yeah I'm holding it down I got oh you
got to refine it Oh interesting
oh [ __ ] oh you like turn it into length
lumber you Whittle it oh my god I'm
getting attacked by a little adorable
thing oh my god ways getting attacked by
his adorable
that's not adorable wait I'm refining
his spine hang on let me just refine
this bad boy into something in there so
this is a shop a shop all right this is
a lot of stuff all at once yeah oh
you're right it is a shop it's like
crops where are we
we're in a beautiful place it's glorious
I'm just getting some wood my dudes how
do we get food and water what do you
think we eat in this world probably
planted protons charging you holy jeez
it is get the cow the cows udders seem
to be on the top of its head is that mad
be steak oh I got it I hate it right in
its scoops oh my god that's yeah what do
I revolve wait oh it's gonna cook itself
but it sounds amazing confetti what is
happening over there a cow with an utter
on its head exploded into confetti
don't ask questions I like these
mechanics so far this world save is very
interactive oh that's nice
you know it's what I'm learning about
Korean is they they use the verb to come
for everything and they don't realize
what that
means in English or has colloquially to
be understood as so you know if they
show up someplace like I came whose
Lyman they're doing like those things
you can say to your dog but not your
wife and Colin just goes come come this
town is too big for the sledgehammer
that what you call it the slammer wait
wait wait come here wait come here wait
come here look at look at look at Bob
from this angle what am i doing
come on man
sauce in my rib here come on oh so your
sauce in something come on come on it's
really putting that wood to work so I'm
like half thirsty can we drive that guys
we're just steeping in over there or
what this is my own private business and
I don't think it has anything to do with
you I think you should let me be we
should we should sorry is there like a
crafting menu uh if you I see backpack
scrap wood block okay I can place this
is much smaller than I thought this is
talk yeah a little block you can place
or like nothing alright wait but did
anyone try drinking the juice from the
juice pond there's a bucket over here is
that good I have a bucket now I can now
throw water on you oh wait we can we can
put the fire out in the ship I bet let's
do it and what good would that do you
don't move like a person I've Schmitt I
made a cross I need some more master
battery to proceed though it's
indestructible ok in the bottom right it
says inventory something and something
what is H and what is L H is how to play
oh there's like a tool oh there's we
need that so bad I desperately need oh
all right camera it out how to build a
vehicle that really jumps from out
to sprint how to build a vehicle Oh Oh
No is this complicates complicated oh no
no oh no yes I guess there's a tiny box
Tim everybody lick so you'd make that
tiny box Tim Wow we got I think we got
to go to that building in the distance
and take stuff from there I don't think
we make that you know like wheels and
stuff I think we got to go get that okay
so there's a battery slot in here if we
put the battery in the ship something
good happens or something okay so we got
to go get a battery I think I just stole
a bunch of parts from the ship I now
have like a switch a headlight toilet
paper a short pipe Oh
potatoes or food oh I wouldn't it all
Bob we're heading to the house I'm
coming you guys have a house my place I
claim this therefore it's all so are we
souped together I don't know if I like
the sound of that I don't think that's
good I made soup with you and you would
betray me like this
hey Marc I just found this structure but
did you see the other structure yeah
that's your structure that's yours this
one's mine this one's mine don't go to
your mind go to yours
I stole a bucket from you I drink this
that's the best thing you want to hear
from this I'm about to do something for
the sake of all of us I'm about to
discover if there's fall damage no
there's no fall damage guys
oh well that's reassuring I've got lots
of seeds I've got lots of soil whoa
that's a scary one oh you got weight you
got it did you just take the loot oh no
that's just for finding an arm then I
found just over here it's just an arm
what I found said whenever I got that
weird that you would keep be still be
talking weird that shut up oh there is
Fault damage I'm no evil no there no no
no I'm in need of so much liquid in my
life
right now I got a liquid you know would
you have consumable liquid duo it's it's
looks like a paint bucket I swear it's
not left mouse button eat I trust you
game oh that was pretty good look oh
that was great liquid that filled my
hunger - you're welcome dude you're
welcome bro oh look I found cows that we
can kill for no apparent reason
oh yeah mark these things blow up into
confetti when they die they also have a
tattoo it son shake on them I think that
means ism company oh wait does have
blunders on its head yeah it does have
owners on fuse know we were lying on you
we were lying on you my dude are you
guys harvesting the brain juice or what
I'm not what if I called a bucket up to
you can I fill this will fill fill my
bucket fill me oh you weren't kidding
these corns are huge yeah you smack them
and they just give you the give you
smooth the corn
wait there's a robo man over there
wailing around coming coming this way oh
oh these guys kind of suck these robos
where are they coming from I so I know
what the description on the store page
said basically so this planet was
populated by automated farming robots
and for some reason these robots that
are supposed to be farming the land for
us so that we can come like colonize our
going rogue and attacking us and we're
intended we need to defend ourselves and
use their scrappy bits for hilarious
building construction purposes these fun
pieces didn't hurt I thought yeah I hit
an I hit a a hive and it just bees
everywhere I thought I was gonna die so
what happens if I eat this corn I cannot
eat this corn okay I can place it on the
ground whoa it corners another building
I got a tote bot I don't know what this
means
I got another component kit I don't know
but oh god there's like a full ocean
with clams and stuff in it oh my god
this underwater is subnautica esque
scary its vast terrifying what did I
just pick up I just picked up crude oil
off of underwater oil geysers you just
happen to pick up a little on top of it
and I just go into the bottle and now I
got some oil is that what the oil rush
was like back in the day people to pick
up bottles of it minted gold bars and
jugs of oil just like Wow where are you
wave you win so you sway the hell out of
here I'm I don't have any I have things
that seem like they would be food but
aren't food yeah I'm I'm like dying of
thirst you need him one another shake if
you have some yeah I do where are you
you're real far away I'm coming I'm over
by where weight is now mark I'm dying
okay come towards you huh you're dying
dying I'm losing one health per second
because of whoa you can put yourself in
third person can you cow yeah hitting
see puts you in third I don't like it
maybe I should look at the tool tips for
food
control air no food food food food mark
do you have any more of those shakes or
we don't running low on food okay we
can't sustain ourselves on shakes alone
oh well I know but how do I get more
juice out of the cow brain no bash it in
its go play anywhere how to make food
and it says all this other complicated
[ __ ] but all I want is food in my life
yeah I've got so much corn what do I do
with the corn do I turn it into ethanol
for fuel why can't I eat it I totally
for real far away your ambitions for
getting back to the ship were stupid
I found the ship
[Music]
criminy crab oh I have more carrot my
problems thirst more than food Ted drink
its chemicals chemical how desperate are
you wait pretty desperate look I'm gonna
do my best to nurse you guys back to
health with all of my findings but you
know it's just
oh yeah though I'm not gonna find a lot
I found paint ammo ammo use the use it
in a paint gun obviously I know but how
do I get a paint gun well that's a fair
question
more paint ammo gas anything it's a
mystery
is there a crafting bench that we don't
know about is there like possibly in the
ship finding a lot of seeds I got a lot
of beet seeds so if I can find a way to
plant some seeds for beets we will be in
pretty good shape is there really
nothing at the top of this building are
they serious yeah I mean we could easily
look up this information but I feel like
it should be in the game so cowsy you go
test their theory shoot milk out of
their heads when they get a glow in them
they milk it you violently if you feed
them corn all right let's try this here
take my corn maybe you put the corn down
and bait the cow and then you milk the
cow you supple suckle at its yeah well
it's eating the corn it's not do Oh it
shot it out oh my god you feed it corn
and you get get cow juice out of the
cows load it out of its head Wade we got
to find some cows like right yesterday
mark where's your cows I dude I'm in the
middle of a forest I found a forest cow
you keep going further away further away
dude I'm swimming in milk
oh god I'm rubbing milk all over me
oh [ __ ] now some good milk oh it comes
out oh it does wait get some feast my
cow feast yeah here I'm putting all my
corns down oh my god I've got three
milks oh it's so good it's good stuff is
good stuff if you have three milks stop
picking them up you a-hole I thought
you've gotten a few hold one milk in my
hand have you been drinking it though
I'm like fully I'm topped up baby
well drink some you idiot you're dying
I'm dying but I didn't drink any milk
yet why whenever you turn the milk into
cheese or something loaded that cow into
funfetti earlier I told you whatever we
were just experimenting but then you did
get meat so you got it like milk them
for all their liquid once they're out of
liquid then you get your meat what's
what's that cow a making no more juicy
all right well now I feel good that
we're not gonna just die I don't feel
like we're worse crap mechanicing
anything yet can you try to figure out
the soil stuff yeah I'm gonna head back
to the ship is the ship in your base of
operations screw the ship you need to
stop latching onto the ship and start
grabbing onto dreams that are waiting
for you out in the woods I didn't get a
chance to clear my internet browser
history and it's on the ship you need to
go fly out of the nest
what what could you possibly have been
looking up that we would be shocked by
uncle Scoob uncle uncle scoops scoops
only com use the lift for something what
do you use it for I need to get up oh
you can lift yourself okay so I'm gonna
look at this playbook okay so one okay
so there's build a base from blocks on
the lift place or acquired bearings
wheels driver seats okay we don't have
bearings we don't have wheels we have
one bearing one wheel I don't have a
driver's seat but I do have one bearing
one way out listen man calm down how can
you how can one turn this into that I'm
getting milk rich over here I hope it
doesn't spoil cuz I got like 20 milks
coming my way I'm gonna I'm gonna cave
in this [ __ ] I'm the caveman I'm gonna
put a circuit board on the ground my god
you're just he posing and I'm gonna take
a component kid I'm gonna put it on
there hey did I do it I didn't lift it
it's the problem I didn't put it on a
lift
oh yeah right then you put this on that
and you'll hit it with a hammer oh okay
what if I put a lift
on the lift I cannot it's just
impossible really it seems like now
again I do it well cannot oh well that's
disappointing what if you put two lifts
side by side and then I get on the lift
oh oh my god I'm going back to the ship
battery battery we can take yes yes
where would you find a battery right
next to our ship [ __ ] interesting
interesting interesting interesting okay
so
mayhaps if you take that battery but i
believe it's pronounced battery
Oh battery sorry me me on a or we put it
in the ship then the ship will put it to
automatic fire suppression system out
and then we will be able to use the ship
to be able to make the things that we
need to make how many in Dubai Haneda
when it's so convenient that those cows
are bred just shoot milk in jars out of
themselves what every battery appeared
oh I thought you already got it no I
tried to get look it you had a good walk
don't put water on the battery no he's
my router a straight the thing Oh
so you're I got good news I got bad what
did you do water didn't work once water
didn't work
oh I got the battery didn't need water
it's not the right clink ah it was just
sitting right there in the fire okay all
right then let's go wait the please
don't jump off of this
wait jumps a fall but you know there's
no fall damage mark to test that I
tested you know called image there's no
phone there so come on
would I lie would I would I lie ask
yourself that would I lie no no no pop
oops no no big pop scoops move your arms
and not your legs when you thank you
thank you thank you thank you
why are you using what's happening
sheesh it's it's it's the come on don't
be ridiculous all right wait let's see
this happen let's see what we should
have done the first for two minutes all
right over here
all right so master battery oh oh I see
yeah there's a diagram telling us what
we should do creates all these parts
that we need 30 seconds on a connect
tool I'm crafting my own connect to what
you get only one of us can use it at a
time oh man all that time we could have
has been doing that all right you guys
go can you leave me all of your like
wheels
we can make our you know you want the
ammo or here's chemicals let's probably
use full can of gold oh hell yeah yeah
we'll go figure out the farming all
right you got a bow see show smart
here's the salt jeez boss he's a smart
he's a smart I can can I just connect
anything to anything how does this
connect tool work it is it is funny that
all of the things that apparently we
needed to get started were right by Z
right here yeah now we have now we have
lots of goodies and I can just craft
everything we need right away no
problemo oh no problem we got that going
for us
no problem oh oh you didn't need to buy
these you just pick them up they're not
burnt your spoilage it's that's how many
there are
the number is how many there is oh we're
so dumb guys with so dumb go pick them
up at any moment
oh all right so these will be the
carrots BAM boom pow boom all right I
have a scrap engine I have a driver seat
I need three bearings and then I can pay
for the DLC oh I got this farm off a
torrent oh is it
I think about maybe I got too many maybe
I planned too much cuz it only happened
after I planned so many yeah well you
could have gotten away with two rows but
sowed you went to four you greedy [ __ ] I
can't believe you thought you could farm
on this very inhabited planet oh god no
robots robots anggee the robots are
Rangi that's not you don't want angey
robots that's response the whole thing
of this thing right grope robot
Sangeetha robots don't like the farming
that's right we just have to survive how
do we defend
wait did you take
my bucket yeah you have got a bucket you
had a bucket pockets for buckets we have
10 hours in game until robots come kill
us give me a goddamn bucket what we have
one wave of what game these 10 hours
until robots come kill us how do you
know that there's a timer on my plants
it says here I tell you man look this
game got a lot more stressful la quickly
not when the crops are ready to be
harvested okay so you're guessing this
time run the crops is for the robot
murder and not the crops Pig harvestable
you're laughing no one else is laughing
Wade because yes that is exactly what it
is guys we almost have like a vehicle
here can we just keep can we just focus
on what matters
Eve what does matter what what does
matter what is what what matter I'm not
sure this is gonna be the worst
proportion vehicle like that vehicle you
know the more of a more of a bicycle
than a car is that where we're dealing
with over here no it's more of a baking
pan than a vehicle I'm learning okay all
right had some issues I ran into some
production at kerfuffles look you guys
all I'm so glad you guys are having a
haha fun time I'm staring it in big red
letters eight hours left until like the
police come to kill me
fairly certain we're gonna be absolutely
fine what what what evidence do you have
to that what I want evidence because I
just said I'm fairly certain we're gonna
be absolutely follow I don't even need
another wheel what am i doing thank you
I took a wheel off this wheel barrel
I've got another wheel all right we're
good on wheels I actually got them I got
extra wheels well here oh my god you can
take anything wait you can take anything
you
cuz you don't you can say oh you know
what I did
that's stupid okay I have to change the
connection mark calm down mark what are
there nine hours turn to five you want
to put the bearings on the oh do I maybe
need to okay wait I may have made a goof
in the way that I place these hang on
guys three hours okay don't worry don't
worry mark we're really getting we're
really getting this sorted out I think
I'm really scared though two minutes but
those crops are ready or I mean when the
robots attack we're gonna be in a lot of
trouble
we'll be fine I'll be fine wait do you
seriously doubt my intuition that these
robots are gonna come kill us you don't
think you don't think we don't think all
right Wade you ready for this yes
let there be the front wheels aren't
turning yeah the front wheels aren't
turning this is true this is true guys
I'm stranded out here at the farm mark
we're coming why is this life mark don't
worry don't worry I need to craft some
more stuff we'll be there in a minute
aha two minutes tops indubitably I need
more metal mats do we have metal Wade
you have any metal I gave you all the
metal I have other than the lift in the
sledgehammer um Morgan if you have any
metal
No eight seven six
don't worry we're coming over wait
through me
no maybe one come on we're going to see
mark Oh baby
[Music]